[Applause]
the taliban are back in power in
afghanistan
when they last ruled the country they
did so with an iron fist
their medieval interpretation of sharia
law led to public executions stonings
and a huge curtailing of women's rights
they also allowed terrorist groups like
al qaeda to operate freely in the
country leading to major terror attacks
like 9 11.
so now that the taliban are back in
charge in afghanistan what does that
mean for global terrorism
[Music]
the taliban is not technically
considered a terrorist group although
some of its affiliates are
when they were last in power they were
closely associated with osama bin
laden's al-qaeda and allowed them to set
up a base in afghanistan for their
global terrorist network the taliban
refused to hand over bin laden and
al-qaeda in 2001 leading the u.s nato
invasion and the subsequent removal of
the taliban from power in afghanistan
but it was never so much about the
taliban specifically
more about the terror groups that they
let grow in their country
the afghanistan of the late 1990s was
essentially a rogue state the taliban
which was in power was only recognized
by a handful of countries
internationally
this time around the leadership at least
seems to be more concerned with what the
international community actually thinks
about them we are looking to form a
government which is access acceptable to
whole people including all afghans from
every background the taliban say they
want to rule their islamic emirate of
afghanistan and they claim to be less
concerned these days with a global
islamist movement
in the failed negotiations with the u.s
prior to their takeover the taliban even
promised to cut ties with al-qaeda they
also claimed that human rights and
women's rights will be better than
before they go to job they go to market
they are participating in the society
it's as though they're trying to
reinvent the 2021 taliban as less
extreme
so they give restoring messages
um
on giving women
their basic rights but their actions on
the ground or their practices on the
ground or different personally
i would take this
claim with a grain of salt it aims still
aims to uproot eradicate
any
way of life values
that are thought to be incompatible with
their waves of life
a 2018 study identified 21 militant
groups operating in afghanistan that
were against the government
but the main threats come from three of
these groups the haqqani network
al-qaeda an islamic state in the
coruscant province iskp an offshoot of
isis the haqqani network has been
responsible for a number of attacks on
u.s and western forces in afghanistan
since 2001 and in 2012 it was designated
a foreign terrorist group by america and
the uk but they don't have a long
history of attacks outside of
afghanistan that group's leader sarah
judah khani is part of the taliban's
senior leadership
although they are arguably the most
infamous terrorist group in afghanistan
al-qaeda's influence has waned in recent
years
the al-qaeda of old made it a mission to
attack the west but they have started to
move away from this
but they also have close ties with the
taliban and some are worried they could
grow in size and influence once again
this isis affiliate wants to create an
islamic caliphate across afghanistan
pakistan and parts of central asia
the former afghan government considered
them to be a serious threat and the
taliban aren't aligned with them either
the two groups have fought each other in
the past
their ideologies are contradictory
therefore if
the islamic
state of korasan
province wants to exist in afghanistan
it will need to somehow
negotiate with taliban accept their
terms and conditions otherwise
they will be destroyed
but islamic states have been behind some
of the worst attacks on the west in
recent years
so a growing islamic state is something
to be wary of
extremist militant groups need a place
to grow
train and recruit
that is what the old afghanistan under
the taliban offered to al-qaeda and that
led to some of the worst terror attacks
in europe in the u.s
but in 2021 this seems slightly more
complicated the modern day taliban
appears to be more intent on controlling
its own territory rather than giving
harbour to other terrorist organizations
but my intelligence sources tell me that
already other terror groups around the
world have been emboldened by the
taliban victory over the nato troops